I had only seen the clip that you saw
I'd be extremely angry with me too I am
mortified I'm embarrassed and I am very
angry
that's Gayle King responding to backlash
over her interview with Lisa Leslie
about Kobe Bryant the CBS this morning
co-host took to Instagram early Thursday
morning with her side of the story
unbeknownst to me my network put up a
clip from a very wide-ranging interview
totally taken out of context and when
you see it that way it's very jarring
it's jarring to me the back story on
Tuesday gales wide-ranging interview
with the former WNBA star and Kobe's
longtime friend aired it's been said
that his legacy is complicated because
of sexual assault charge which was
dismissed in 2003 2004 is it complicated
for you as a woman as a WNBA player Kobe
was never like that I just never see
have ever seen him being the kind of
person that would be do something to
violate a woman or be aggressive in that
way that's not the person that I know
the network later posted a clip
featuring Gail asking Lisa about Kobe's
2003 rape charge and subsequent criminal
case and people got mad even Snoop Dogg
took to social media with this message
for Gail we expect more from you Gail
don't you hang out with Oprah why are
y'all attacking us we owe people but
here's what Gail wants everyone to know
so I've been told
or have been advised to say nothing but
that's not good enough for me I reached
out to Lisa because I know that she's a
longtime friend of Kobe's to talk about
his legacy and their friendship we had a
really wide-ranging interview talked
about many things and yes we talked
about that court case because that court
case was also come up and I wanted to
get Lisa's take on it as a friend who
knew him well what she thought where
that should stand is it
even a fair question to talk about it
considering he's no longer with us and
that it was resolved or is it really
part of his history I think that the
media should be more respectful at this
time it's like if you had questions
about it you've had many years to ask
him that it was very powerful when she
looked me in the eye as a member of the
media to say it's time for the media to
leave it alone and to back off and I
insisted I insisted that that part be in
the interview because I thought that it
put a nice button on that part of the
conversation the 61 year old journalist
goes on to explain that the initial
feedback about her interview with Lisa
was all positive but she's not okay with
the network posting the clip about
Kobe's legal battle or the network to
take the most salacious part when taken
out of context and put it up online for
people who didn't see the whole
interview is very upsetting to me and
there will be a very intense discussion
about that in a statement to ET a
spokesperson for CBS News explains quote
Gail conducted a thoughtful wide-ranging
interview with Lisa Leslie about the
legacy of Kobe Bryant an excerpt was
posted that did not reflect the nature
and tone of the full interview we are
addressing the internal process that led
to this and changes have already been
made when Kobe was 24 he was charged
with one count of felony assault after a
then 19-year old woman went to the
police claiming he sexually assaulted
her in his Colorado hotel room back in
2003 the case was dropped in 2004 after
the accuser declined to testify the same
woman also filed a civil suit which was
settled out of court in 2005 I've never
done one of these before I didn't even I
I've never done one of these before but
this was so important to me that I felt
I had to say something I don't want to
sit up on his set and read a prepared
remark I wanted you to hear exactly
where I'm coming from and how empty
than to let everybody know that no
disrespect intended and now I've got to
go to work I thank you for listening
Bryant along with his 13 year old
daughter Gianna and seven others died in
a helicopter crash on January 26 he will
be missed but he will not be forgotten
that's for sure